le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous
présente lien social le Conseil général
au côté des
Réunionnais les violences conjugales
sont un véritable fléo à la Réunion
chaque année plus de 1600 plaintes sont
déposées par des femmes victime de
violence et encore cela ne constitue
probablement que la partie visible de
l'iceberg car encore trop de femmes
n'usent pas porter plainte face à ce
fléo la mobilisation de tous est
nécessaire comment essayer de vaincre
ces violences on en parle tout de suite
dans lien
[Musique]
social avec près de 5 million d'euros
consacrés chaque année le Conseil
général est un acteur majeur de la lutte
contre les violences faites aux femmes
la collectivité finance divers
dispositifs hébergement et transport
d'urgence pour les victimes la moitié
des salaires des assistantes sociales
déployé dans les commissariats ou
gendarmerie mais aussi le numéro vert
0800 2250 55
55 plus de 200 appels ont été
comptabilisés à ce numéro à connaître et
à
mémoriser le département finance aussi
des associations qui œuvrent dans ce
domaine comme le cvif avec lequel il a
déployé des agents de cohésion familiale
dans les collèges qui peuvent être des
référents pour les collégiens comme pour
leurs parents malgré tout ceci et malgré
les actions menées par les autres
intervenants dans l'état les violences
faites aux femmes restent nombreuses
Béatrice nickelin a été victime de
violence en septembre 2011 elle témoigne
de l'horreur en tris fois deors et en
trois fois
bon trouvé un cas tout ça il a toujours
trouvé solution pour revenir 24 he sur
24 m'avait peur parce qu'il était
surveille à moi il m'avait compris que
bon ben si veut parler il ve reste là et
que Mo veut pas ben Iloi
ou c'était vraiment de semaines de
cauchemar que me l'a passé avant
que ce jourlà me trou que ma fille était
très était très fort ce jour-là ben le
rélex que l'il a eu ramasse ma main met
au frais appelle les urgces c'est grâce
à ma fille que est vivant et que
maintenant ma main au bout de par déjà
Mo chaud hein com l'a réveillé comment
est sortie du coma en face de ma télé et
puis bon la famille aussi la M la mne
JAL pour moi là et là m'a réalisé que
cette annéelà en 2011
avait six femmes g coup de sa au total
avait six femmes et toutes les morts
sauf moi mais est rentré dans le
tribunal en tant que victime et quand on
est ressorti mais m'avait l'impression
de d'être accusé parce que les paroles
de l'avocat au moment de son pldar queon
peut pas rebondir sur ses paroles m
donné m'a pu supporter le le 5 ou le 6
janvier 2014 ma fait tentative de
suicide et pensa que mon i quoi parce
que me connais pas nager comme il
connais la requin tu là le requin était
pas au rendez-vous et la M la jette en
moi quoi me connais pas parce que bon
essayie comme comen m essaie d'amélior
mon mon quotidien mais mais nous les
brisé à vie dans un couple là ben si par
exemple on a a un est violent et et
l'autre les subit moi c'est ce que a
fait essayer de de comment essayer de de
comprendre l'autre pourquoi elle est
comme ça essayer d'apporter des solution
tant que la la personne la personne le
violent et le profiteur tant que luit
tant que luit dans son tête il a pas
encore compris qu' il est en train de
faire Malot ben on Nura pas une solution
on on a connu des personnes aussi comme
ça et quand raconte histoire même si le
bonhomme il tape pas mais considère
quand même que c'est comment ça comment
dire ça la maltraitance quand même parce
que quand on VO quelqu'un par exemple il
abuse dessus il n pas la main sur mais
seulement il é sorti des trucs comme ça
quoi comme il réfléchit à tout ça il me
dit bon ben puisque bon la mor veut pas
de moi et bon ben essaie d'améliorer mon
vie un peu mieux que ça et d'arrêter de
d'être enfermé dans mon cas et essayer
de sortir un
maximum améliore mon vie essayer de de
vivre un peu dans la bonne humeur tout
ça quoi parce que si M assise me
réfléchit me commence à penser tout ça
et bon voilà mon TTI blo onê il bloque
et puis voilà quoi ce sont de telles
situations que des milliers de
réunionnaises endurent chaque jour pour
que cela cesse il faut un véritable
changement de mentalité d'éducation d'où
le travail réalisé auprès des collégiens
qui depuis 2 ans en lien avec le
rectorat sont associés à la Journée
internationale pour l'élimination des
violences faites aux femmes chaque 25
novembre il faut aussi la mobilisation
de tous et notamment des artistes comme
marie Alice
marine de cette édition mais on le sait
ces changements prendront du temps et en
attendant un numéro vert peut sauver une
vie à la Réunion 0800 22 55 55 en
métropole est accessible à la Réunion le
115 et le
3919 le Conseil Général de la Réunion
vous a présenté lien social le Conseil
général au côté des
Réunionnais